quand on parcourt facebook encore
aujourd'hui on peut lire il ya pas mal
de parents inquiets à propos du vaccin
contre le vph un vaccin qui est donné
chaque année à des élèves à travers le
pays est-ce que ce vaccin études en
amérique
[Musique]
d'abord est-ce que c'est vrai que le
vaccin ne protège pas contre tous les
types de vph
oui c'est vrai parce qu'il existe une
centaine de types du virus du papillome
humain
le vaccin protège contre 9 2 cv ph
est ce que c'est vrai que des personnes
sont mortes après avoir été vaccinée la
compagnie muc a testé deux gros un
groupe avec le premier vaccin qu'elle a
développé le gardasil et l'autre groupe
avec le gardasil 9 chacun des groupes de
cinq personnes qui sont décédées
mais regardez les causes accident
voiture écrasement d'avion suicide
hémorragie cérébrale leucémie choc
septique blessures par balles
tu meurs manifestement mort inexpliquée
en aucun cas on a été capable de faire
le lien entre les morts et le vaccin bon
et puis l'éternelle question est ce que
c'est vrai que ce vaccin provoque
beaucoup d'effets secondaires une bonne
respiration au québec depuis 2008 sur
près d'un million de doses 330 personnes
vaccinées contre le vph ont eu des
effets secondaires inhabituels une
réaction allergique par exemple ou
encore une rougeur sur la peau si tu
ma grand maman peut donner du style et
non l'organisation mondiale de la santé
le considère comme un vaccin extrêmement
sûres évidemment le but ultime de cette
vaccination c'est d'éradiquer certains
types de cancer mais y est toujours
possible qu'une lésion ce forme et
qu'elle se développe
ultime mans en cancer même son oeil
vaccin c'est pourquoi les femmes doivent
continuer à avoir leurs papiers est si
vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque chose
sécurité